I wonder for the doctor if ranking his
companions would be like somebody
ranking their exes would it just be like
weird and skeevy it's Sunday which means
more Doctor Who content yes if you did
not know around here every single Sunday
new Doctor Who video and I have been
overdue to revisit my ranking of the
modern era Doctor Who companions so that
is precisely what I'm gonna do today
so before I get into this cuz there's a
lot of them to do allow me to reiterate
my criteria for how I choose to define a
companion a companion is any character
who appears in more than one story
because also remember with me two
partners only count as one story because
otherwise we end up with a crap ton of
one-offs many of which are very good but
that's kind of a separate list in my
mind and also they have to have traveled
in the TARDIS at least once and we need
to know that they did not implied but
know so there are a number of characters
who aren't on this list that I'm other
people are gonna be like well aren't
they your companion they traveled in
time order yes we know they travel
through time but we didn't see them
enter or leave the TARDIS as part of
that time travel and the TARDIS is not
the only way to travel through time so
unless we saw them definitively entering
or entering the TARDIS right before it
went somewhere or exhibiting the target
fault the TARDIS following a landing
then that doesn't count as having
travelled in the TARDIS I'm really
strict on this and even with these
strict parameters I've got something I
have to deal with that I really wish I
didn't have to let's get through this
I've got 21 to cover let's start with
the bottom of the barrel well actually
technically they have 22 but I'm lumping
the two bottom ones together so that's
Angie and already Maitland these were
the kids that Clara was nannying I guess
like these kids are the worst they are
awful they are terrible they're I
I'm so irritated I even have to talk
about them they are ungrateful for the
trip they are whiny they're useless to
the plot they're not helpful they're
annoying they distract and detract from
an episode that otherwise might have
actually not even might have would have
worked significantly better without
their presence namely a nightmare and
silver.we I mean there are other things
wrong with that episode but they're a
big part of it I don't even want to keep
talking about them I'm gonna move on
so number 20 Adam Mitchell from series 1
also a very bad companion big difference
between him and Angie and already though
and the reason he ranks above them is
he's a bad companion by design he is
supposed to be crap at this he is
supposed to make stupid of awful stories
because this was still early in the
revival and it helped to illustrate that
roses ability to travel with the doctor
and follow his rules well enough to be
able to continue to travel with him and
not you know mess around to a degree
that would force him to ditch her and
that not everyone has the ability to do
that some people screw up and as a
result they get booted and it's sort of
it helps sell rose a little bit honestly
and so he does serve a function he still
allows a companion though number 19
Jackie Tyler Jackie is a character who
has it's funny
she's grown on me a little bit I I don't
find her as irritating as I once did
that said that softening is not enough
to actually get her moved any higher
than third from bottom which was the
same place she was last time I did this
so I mean the thing about me part of the
problem with Jackie is not her about
what she represents I don't like how
much the domestic home life of
companions has eaten up time in the show
and she's kind of the embodiment of what
annoys me about it and she again not
necessarily a terrible character but I
just I don't particularly enjoy spending
as much time with her as we do number
eight
Dean Courtney woods the other kid who
travels with the with the doctor got me
definitely better than Angie and Artie
and honestly could have been decent it
doesn't help that she got saddled with
some not very good episodes that she was
stuck in like she shows up in the
caretaker which is a Matt episode she's
in kill the moon which isn't I will
maintain is not as bad an episode as a
lot of people think it is
up until the ending where it goes
completely off the freakin rails but
it's still not great and her involvement
in that is ancillary like it doesn't
feel like her traveling with the doctor
to be part of that story changes the
story it feels like that story would
have been the same with or without her
which makes her just kind of pointless
now those bottom four are honestly
pretty much the only ones who that I can
actually say I don't like everybody from
here even though some of these are
pretty far down the list I like so it's
just a question of who I like more
although in the number of cases I'm
gonna be pointing out their faults and
to explain why they're not higher but
please understand from here on out I
actually like all these to some degree
or other number seventeen Canton Everett
Delaware I just find him to be very men
in black it's a little bit like men and
black invade Doctor Who in terms of his
his outlook and how well he's prepared
to just roll with what's going on and I
kind of like that about him and I think
the reason he occupies the bottom error
area of you know campaigns that I like
in some degree is that as much as I like
him as a character he's he's barely
counts as a companion in terms of you
know his is used in the story and and
everything else but I I do
I do enjoy him I think he is he's the
fun addition especially for the for the
time frame and you know getting him at
super old was also kind of adorable
number 16
Brian Williams Rory's father he's down
this far because similar to Jackie it's
the domestics thing it'd take a
character has to be really phenomenal
for them to tie into the domestics but
still place really high and he's better
than Jackie and I do you I feel like you
learn a lot about Rory
by spending time with his father and and
I enjoy that and I appreciate it now
part of the reason he is down as far as
he is is because I'm not counting PS in
this like I I know a lot of people
there's no reason to not consider it
Canon because it certainly doesn't
contradict anything but did it it's a
bonus scene as far as I'm concerned it's
unfinished it wasn't even shot it's
beautiful and I liked it but I'm not
factoring that into his ranking if I was
maybe it would maybe he'd be a little
higher but this is where he lands number
15 rigsy it was nice having him back and
I do wish I could put him higher the
problem is when he came back a second
time and therefore qualified him for a
place on this list he was more of a plot
point than an active participant in
things which was a shame
because I really liked him in flat line
I thought he was a lot of fun and I
thought his dynamic with Capaldi was
really good I liked him as a character I
liked the way he reacted and interacted
with this weirdness going on he actually
bounced off car pretty well too so I did
like him but his second appearance felt
underwhelming in many ways I felt coming
out of flatland like he could totally be
the nice companion and then like when he
actually returned I don't know if it was
a case of they just didn't really have
good use form or what but it did may go
like oh look at that our number one
draft pick only kind of managed to bunt
that probably made no sense I should not
use force analogies number 14 the one
that I'm gonna have to explain very
carefully Sarah Jane Smith so Sarah Jane
Smith understand that my ranking for her
and this list is exclusively taking into
account her appearances in New Era Dr
Who I am not taking into consideration
any of her classic work nor am i taking
into consideration Sarah Jane Adventures
this is limited only to her main show
appearances since the revival and based
solely on those she is a wonderful piece
of nostalgia but doesn't do a lot to
elevate beyond that I mean she's she's
good and I think even if you don't know
who she was even if you didn't watch
classic so her appearance still works in
and of itself but she's there to be the
hook into the old show and for that
purpose
she works extremely well but I can't in
good conscious Ness place her above the
other companions in terms of her new era
appearances because it is banking so
heavily on that nostalgia again banking
well yields good dividends but if I'm
not taking the root of that nostalgia
into account this is just where she ends
up number 13 Mickey Smith so Mickey was
annoying at first I considered him part
of the domestics cuz even though you
know he's not you know related to Rowe
strictly speaking being her boyfriend
and being earthbound he felt like
another thing they kept telling the show
back to modern era earth all the dang
time which I you know annoyed me then it
really irritates me now but he did
evolve into a fairly interesting
character I liked watching his
transition and his evolution and his
gaining a sense of adventure his gaining
a sense of independence is gaining a
sense of eventual kind of badassery
I liked it and I think ultimately what
sells me on him is the way hey I think
it was actually the meta-crisis doctor
no no it is the doctor because
meta-crisis was was off the TARDIS
getting ready to blow up the Daleks and
all the companions are jumping on and
Mickey comes on and
tenth tenet is there McKay it's just
something about the fun in his voice I'm
like yeah that's the right tone for this
guy number twelve the always
controversial Clara Oswald I didn't go
back and check I have a feeling this is
probably a similar place to where she
landed last time I did this list and
honestly she's probably bounced her if
I'd done this list I don't know a year
ago I might have put her higher or I
might have put her lower it's a matter
of trying I'm not sure I'm not sure
succeeding but trying very hard not to
hold hell-bent against her as a
character oh yeah overly so it is
relevant to her ranking because it's the
overselling of her character that drives
all of a lot of the bad decisions of
that episode but it's not it's certainly
not the fault of Jenna Coleman if
nothing else but the thing with Clara is
I did not like her with Smith
I thought they had lousy chemistry and I
hated the hole in pot the mystery of the
impossible girl because she wasn't a
character she was a plot device and she
didn't even feel characterized she felt
very Hollow now her first series with
Capaldi I actually came to like her
quite a bit there I rather enjoyed her
unfertile I think her chemistry with
Capaldi much better than she had with
Smith she finally felt like a fully
formed character I'd like the stuff that
goes on with Danny pink I like what that
says about her I like the way that
impacts her I like the way that impacts
her relationship with the doctor um but
then we get her last series we get
series 9 there are parts that are one
basically leading up to face the Raven
and if she had stayed dead with face the
Raven she
definitely be higher than this cuz it
felt like a proper build up to that
death because she you know was trying to
emulate the doctor so much and then how
far she pushed it was what got her
killed cuz she thought well he could
handle this I can handle this and she
couldn't and she died and then oh then
hell bent habit as I said I I don't want
to overly ding the character for the
monstrous sins of this one episode but
ultimately I feel the fairest thing I
can do is basically just leave her where
she was last time I did this ranking
number 11 Rose Tyler a lot of people got
really enamored with Rose I never really
did I like rose I like her spunk I like
her street smarts I like her toughness I
like her humanity her sense of empathy
that was good especially with the with
Eccleston I didn't love the romantic
elements with her in Tennant and as much
as I liked her as a character even
setting that aside I don't love her
so it just becomes one of those things
where oh she's fine and again I know
some people really love rose and they
think she's the end-all be-all and
yellow you know good for you folks but
she's not for me she's just she's fine
but now we get into the top ten so let's
start this little bit of the list with
nardole I really do like not at all I
think again Matt Lucas is not an actor
I've ever really warmed to he's not
someone who I'm like oh I can't stand
that guy but he would show up and stuff
and be like yeah I feel like this guy's
just got a stock a bit that he does and
he kind of feeds into that a little bit
here but it it doesn't feel like a bit
it does actually feel like a character
at least once he became the companion I
actually don't really like his
appearance on the husbands of River Song
but once he was traveling with the
doctor and the way he tempered with and
also stood up to Capaldi I really
enjoyed there are moments that it still
breaks like when he gets all sort of
and shrieky that feels weird that feels
forced
so there are some moments that like that
that bring him down a little bit but I
enjoyed our talk quite a bit I think
he's fun I think he's funny I like that
he's kind that he certainly has moments
where he comes across as tougher than
you'd think just for his willingness to
stand up to the doctor the way he does
number nine Rory Williams or you know
mr. Pond as as the doctor would prefer
to think of him as I can you remember I
said about Mickey same thing for Rory
but better first of all I liked him you
know earlier on than I did Mickey and
where he ends you know having his badass
moments and having it all center around
Amy and his is just looking at a at a
Cyberman in the face going where is my
wife and the commitment from him the
devotion to her but also just the
strength of his own character and his
you know pushing to help because as much
as he's he's there because of Amy he he
proves himself as a companion in his own
right and I really like his dynamic I
like I like the dynamic of that trio
actually a lot
Rory Amy and the doctor and all three of
them have great chemistry with all three
with each one of them has good chemistry
with the other two and collectively as a
group they work really great and yeah I
enjoy worry quite a bit number eight
River Song
I know some people who really can't
stand her and a lot of people point to
her as like the epitome of Moffat isms
when it comes to him writing female
characters and while I can't necessarily
dispute that I still like her she's fun
I love how fun she is I love her sense
of adventure and I love the sense of
emotional weight just lurking behind the
surface of that we get that you know
right from the first encounter that we
have with her
I really enjoy getting to understand her
dynamic with the doctor better every
single time we see her and filling in a
little more and learning a little more
and and sort of having a picture painted
where she is what she presented herself
as from the first time we saw her but
there is also more feeling and emotion
behind that then maybe she would even
like us to be aware of and certainly
more than she's comfortable showing the
doctor a lot of the time and I enjoyed
her with all three doctors that she
appeared with I don't know if it's worth
ever bringing her back again probably
would like to see her with Whitaker but
at the end of the day I really do feel
that husband's a River Song was a good
send-off for her as a character I think
it's time to be done but I did enjoy her
time number seven this I consider to be
the biggest corrective verses the
ranking that I did last time I did this
number seven Martha Jones significantly
upgraded from the last time I did this
ranking because the thing was I
basically last time I did this I counted
the fact that the story kind of treated
her like crap as a knock against her as
a character and that was unfair what I
said last time I did this list was I
called her the rebound companion which
is accurate but as a character she is
better than that as a performance Freema
Agyeman gives better than that this is a
character that is better than she got
and the thing is there are points where
the show actually does acknowledge that
I'm not sure it acknowledges it as fully
as it could it still ultimately did
short shrift Martha as a character and
most of her sort of repeat appearances
after making the very smart and strong
decision to leave I didn't
honor her as much as I would have liked
them to but Martha's a great character
Martha is smart Martha is compassionate
Martha has a terrific rapport with
Tennant Martha is a great companion
written into scenarios that treated her
as disposable which was unfair because
she's really good number six
Captain Jack Harkness now much like when
I mentioned Sarah Jane Smith I am not
counting anything other than the main
appearances here difference is not
counting up additional appearances hurt
Sarah Jane versus where she might
otherwise have landed for Jack that's
doing him a favor because I like him on
here so much better than on Torchwood
because on here
it's like whether it's like with River
he's fun I love how much funny is I
especially when he was paired with
Eccleston he was good with Tennant but
when he was with that constant it was
perfect because he had that sense of
swash buckling swagger battle Stan
didn't have and that's not like a
deficiency on ethical since part his
version of the darker wasn't designed to
be that that's why Jack was there and
that's why he fits so well lieutenant it
was slightly more redundant because
Tennant had that swagger and so you
didn't need another character to Ted to
have it but Jack is just so much fun and
the the feel and the weight of his
immortality in something like utopia I
think is just gets the balance right
versus how overplayed they do the
eternal angst in Torchwood Jack is Jack
is just fun and I love fun it's hard to
it's hard to be fun for me here we go
folks
top five number five Amy Pond
I think in my head I still think of her
as Emilia though funny I like Amy a lot
I especially like the dynamic as built
with her and Smith that she because of
what happened to her as a kid that she
encountered him and he basically
abandoned her without meaning to that
she is both enamored with him but also
kind of over him she can't stop she
can't resist him but she's really
irritated by him and kind of already fed
up with his crap I love that balance I
love the way they do Karen Gillan and
she's just a magnetic performer she's on
screen you have to look at her you can't
not watch this woman and again I'll
mention the chemistry with between her
and Smith between her Smith and and Rory
it's it's also good that dynamic of
those three and in herself on her own
and seeing some of the things she goes
through in episodes like Amy's choice
and the girl who waited there are
wonderful explanations that go into even
more detail as to why she is such a good
character and I think possibly the only
reason she does not rank higher than
number five is because they decided to
have her want to jump the doctors bones
which was totally unnecessary I really
wish they hadn't done that cuz yeah she
could have been top three material
otherwise number four bill Potts now I
have a completely separate video a
rather lengthy one addressing the idea
of Bill as being an agenda pushing
companion there should be a little link
up there assuming that I did this right
so I'm not even going to address that
aspect what I will say is there were
were a lot of people who even after the
arguments I presented saying how she
wasn't I don't believe that she was
agenda pushing or definitely not to the
degree that people assert that she is
there were still a lot of people said
yeah but she's got no character and I
think I'm at I'm like what show were you
watching
she's so much character she is a lot of
developed character I mean the doctor
himself says it when she has her first
appearance in the pilot where you know
he says to her you know I say something
that people don't understand everyone
else frowns you smile she likes to be
challenged she loves new experiences she
loves wanting to understand the universe
better and that's reflected in the kinds
of questions that she asks and I know
people like can be all sort of snarky
but I was like Oz you can read the robot
two emojis bro that's her frame of
reference she wants to understand and I
love her dynamic with Capaldi it is a
teacher-student relationship it's
reminiscent in in some ways of the
seventh doctor and ace so I I think she
has a lot going on his character I think
she's got a lot of personality I think
she her youth is well Illustrated I feel
like she is the most properly youthful
character since Rose honestly cuz Rose
had a very youthful energy you know
Martha was more mature uh as she should
be she's about to become a doctor Donna
was kind of her own her own thing but
you know get into someone like Amy and
Rory Amy starts immature but we get to
see her mature over the time and then
Clara I mean they really didn't seem to
know what they wanted Clara to be for a
good chunk of her run but Bill is
inquisitive but also but has that much
younger energy and again paired with how
old and crotchety Capaldi could be I
think she's I think she's awesome I like
Bill I I was gonna say I get why other
people don't but I'm sorry
I don't I love her so here we go top
three the highest new entrant on the
list this this was a character not up
for consideration prior when I did this
list before character actually had not
even been introduced number three Missy
yeah you heard me right Missy because
you know yeah she's the master she's
villain she's a problem in series eight
the problem series nine
but in series 9 you start to see that
playfulness move over slightly to be a
little bit less megalomaniacal although
I was always going to say less malicious
I'm not sure it is but a little less
ambitious perhaps and then in series 10
in the vols with her interactions with
Capaldi and then actually traveling with
him and actually trying to work together
and seeing them in something like world
enough in time I in my head it will be
one of the great Oh should've bins I
would say honestly right up there with
Paul McGann have been getting at least
his own complete series you know outside
of that movie is the idea of a series of
Capaldi's doctor twelfth doctor and
Missy as his companion I think that
almost could be like my ideal dream
series right there I love their dynamic
and their interaction and their
chemistry together so much and I love
Missy as a character and to me she
always did feel like the master but she
did feel like a new incarnation a new
variation but she still felt true to
that character
I liked her as a villain I loved her
even more during the episodes where I
believe she does qualify as a companion
so we get to our top two and I kind of
hope you didn't go back and look at my
old one because if you did then you
already know these top two because they
haven't changed so number two Wilfred
I said way back when I talked about
Rory's dad that it takes a lot for me to
overlook the domestic roots of a
character to have them rise above that
this is a domestic character and he's
number two that should say almost
everything about how good he is Wilf is
a phenomenal character in and of himself
his sense of energy without ever feeling
childish never losing the weight of his
age the weight of his experiences and
him him sitting down to talk with
Tennant in the end of time and you know
shifting so quickly from looking down at
the earth and saying I was down there
you know private mocked and then turned
to the doctor we must look like ants to
you like that's that should be an
awkward gear shift maudlin awful it's
wonderful it's perfect and then he he
breaks my heart and he makes me cry when
he tries to hand the doctor the gun and
he's choking up calling the doctor the
post Mon wonderful man he's ever known
and that he doesn't want him to die Oh
Wilf is wonderful and amazing and there
is only one person who could possibly
rank above him that is his own
granddaughter Donna Noble Donna
is to me the perfect companion because
she is the best friend she's the friend
who is happy to travel with you
the friend who every now and then wants
a little breathing space the friend who
is not clingy but who values you the
friend who will call you out on your
crap
the friend who will praise you when you
get it right
she is the doctors best friend and
thankfully the show acknowledges that
with those words best friend and that is
everything that I want that I love in a
companion relationship there are other
dynamics that can work I can enjoy a
certain amount of antagonism I can enjoy
you know the the mentor student type
relationship but at the end of the day
if you ask me what do I want out of a
companion relationship I want a
friendship an established friend not a
building one but something that feels
like these two feel like they've been
doing this forever and it feels like
they could keep doing it forever and
that is Donna that is Donna in the
TARDIS and it makes her exit so much
more painful and tragic to know that she
could have had fun and been good for the
doctor to be with him forever for as
long as she lasted and that is why Donna
Noble still remains number one companion
for me so that will wrap up this rear
ankle what are your thoughts on it you
do not have to list all 21 that I went
through why'd you stick to a top 10 or
top 5 or just a number one or just a
bottom five whatever mood you're in
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it do all the stuff you know
the stuff like and subscribe and follow
me on Twitter support me on patreon
that's kind of a big one links for all
that stuff and more is down in the
description so until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]